le fils bonjour
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver ce
matin dans la matinale alors selon le
dernier sondage et lab 57% des français
ont le sentiment que leur pouvoir
d'achat a baissé depuis le début du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron la réalité
n'est-elle pas plus préoccupante
je crois que ce sondage n'est qu'un pâle
reflet d'une réalité qui est devenu
beaucoup plus inquiétante car un certain
nombre de catégories sont sont pointés 1
par ce sondage ont
les catégories je lirai habituel les
ouvriers les ruraux qui sont pour partie
les gilets jaunes des employés est alors
fait nouveau fait son entrée la couche
moyenne à les professions intermédiaires
se montre aujourd'hui parmi les
préoccupent et alors ce que le sondage
ne ne dit pas c'est que en réalité à
côté des 10 ou 12 millions de pauvres et
on peut penser que le chiffre est
beaucoup supérieur il y à toutes ces
personnes vulnérables que le credoc a
estimé à environ 4 millions alors qui
comprend tous ceux qui n'ont pas été
cités me semble-t-il dans ce sondage et
les jeunes les jeunes étudiants les
jeunes actifs du secteur privé surtout
quand ils sont en contrat précaire est
chargé de famille de surcroît les femmes
surtout quand elles sont issus de
familles monoparentales les chômeurs
quand ils sont en fin de droits ou
qu'ils ont peu de droits à faire valoir
et puis n'oublions pas les retraités
ceux qui ont des carrières hachées mais
également ceux qui sont dans des
secteurs particulièrement préoccupant je
pense notamment aux agriculteurs et aux
travailleurs aux travailleurs
indépendants donc on a on a une francine
y seraient en réalité si on voulait
résumer il y a aujourd'hui de france il
ya une france riche et aisée qui
d'ailleurs ne doit pas comprendre ce
dont nous parlons ce matin et puis la
france la plus nombreuse
c'est une france pauvre qui s'est
appauvrie
une france vulnérables précaires qui
risque à tout instant de tomber dans la
dans la réalité il faut bien avoir
conscience que derrière ces chiffres il
y à des êtres humains il y à des hommes
des femmes des enfants 1 qui souffrent
au quotidien
on sait depuis longtemps qu'il ya
effectivement des personnes qui vivent
dans leur voiture un qui vivent dans des
caves dans des parkings voilà c'est ça
la réalité aujourd'hui la pauvreté donc
pour vous c'est en bien plus au delà en
tout cas de ce que de scanner ce sondage
oui bien sûr je crois qu'on a un
appauvrissement réel alors évidemment ce
qui est assez préoccupant en démocratie
c'est qu'on a parallèlement un
enrichissement qui est aussi bien réel
fait on a beaucoup parlé de l'epargne
qui a été amassée par les français
durant durant la crise mais ce que l'on
n'a pas dit c'est que 70% de cette
épargne a été réalisée par 20% des
ménages aisés 1 selon le donc l'enquète
l' enquête du credoc donc on assiste à 7
à cette situation que les plus riches
durant la crise se sont enrichis encore
un l'image des patrons des grands
groupes qui soit américain ou français
un bon amazon facebook
microsoft et puis bernard arnault pour
l'industrie du luxe en france 1 la
fortune des dix premiers milliardaires a
été multiplié par deux en un an donc ça
accrédite cette thèse de deux francs ce
qui semble aujourd'hui complètement tiré
conciliables complètement éloignées
l'une de l'autre et du coup michel la
situation actuelle marquée par
d'importantes hausses de prix de
produits tente énergétique alimentaire
est ce que cela ne risque pas au fond de
conduire un nouveau grand mouvement
social comme celui des gilets jaunes en
vous savez on n'a pas besoin d'être
expert pour dire que 2021 c'est 2018 en
pire 1 je rappelle que la hausse des
carburants a été l'élément détonateur du
mouvement des gilets jaunes en novembre
18 aujourd'hui beaucoup plus encore de
gilet jaune sont préoccupés par cette
hausse vertigineuse alors on annonce
évidemment des mesures
immédiates ou qui vont l'être comme un
chèque carburant mais on parle aussi
d'un chèque de 50 à 60 euros mais 50 à
60 euros pour passer tout l'automne et
tout l'hiver ou 50 à 60 euros
mensuels payés tout ça ce sont des
rustines c'est pas ainsi qu'on va
effectivement enrayer cette formidable
hausse du pouvoir d'achat qui touche
encore à la fois les actifs les
retraités les jeunes les seniors les
personnes en ehpad ou qui ne sont pas en
ehpad les hommes les femmes et tout le
monde est aujourd'hui concerné c'est ce
que l'on pourrait appeler la
nationalisation de la pauvreté de la
précarité
merci beaucoup michel pour votre analyse
et on attend évidemment là les mesures
du gouvernement qui ne saurait tarder
concernant la led pour les automoblistes
justement sur le prix de l'essence et la
piste en tout cas d'un d'un chèque est
censée la piste privilégiée pour
l'instant bruno le maire l'a confirmé
hier en tout cas la piste des taxes est
exclu pour l'instant merci michel fize